esta lista en el estudio rosa perez
masdéu para hablar de el foco de la
prensa internacional rosa y por supuesto
vamos a abrir esta sección con el foco
mediático internacional pero con un
punto de vista distinto algo alternativo
nos fijamos en al yazira que titula los
ucranianos afrontan el juego del gato y
el ratón con calma con una calma pues
que está reinando en el ambiente pese a
esta atención no rosa buenos días raúl
exactamente nos fijamos en esta crónica
de lis cookman que está redactada desde
mariupol una ciudad de 500 mil
habitantes en la región de dónetsk y
ella la periodista lo que describe es
como decías en el titular una calma
estoica de hecho habla de niños jugando
en los parques de adolescentes patinando
sobre hielo dice textualmente no parece
un país en vísperas de una posible
invasión de rusia a gran escala de hecho
uno de los vecinos de la ciudad que dan
su opinión en este texto dice parece que
occidente está más preocupado por
nosotros de lo que lo estamos nosotros
mismos de hecho las personas aquí hablan
con la periodista dicen que ven poco
probable una invasión rusa pero que la
tensión podría durar indefinidamente
dicen el juego del gato y el ratón acaba
de empezar y en el mismo sentido james
byrd words en el moscú times hace una
crónica desde la capital rusa y habla
con distintas personas y también and
escribe pues un escenario tranquilo
habla de floristas que retiran las
flores que han sobrado de san valentín
personas que pasean bajo el sol de
invierno y dicen que si bien la relación
con ucrania es complicado no creen que
se vaya a materializar finalmente un
ataque un ataque perdón dice uno de los
hombres no queda su opinión putin es muy
listo no permitiría una guerra
especialmente entre rusos y ucranianos
rosa y ahora nos venimos hacia nuestra
región porque en chile murió cristina
calderón la última hablante del pueblo
yagán tal y como lo titula el diario de
argentina rosa efectivamente ella era la
última hablante competente de este
lenguaje oral y originario de la tierra
del fuego y bien si sus hijos tal y como
señaló su hija a la agencia efe no
llegaron a aprender el idioma por miedo
a ser discriminados justificadamente
según ha señalado su hija su nieta así
que antes de que muriera pues se
cristina calderón creó un diccionario y
un libro de leyendas de hecho el libro
se llama quiero contarte un cuento y
recoge pues esto la tradición de este
idioma pues que ya está a punto de
desaparecer y ahora hablamos de la
posibilidad rosa de colonizar el planeta
marte esta es la propuesta que defiende
la marzo fire in y este reportaje que
vamos a ver de james oliver con white
the guardian- nos muestra cómo viven los
voluntarios de este proyecto de
simulación rosa efectivamente este es un
proyecto que se desarrolla entre otros
lugares en el desierto de ayuda de eeuu
y básicamente se trata de seis
voluntarios seleccionados entre cientos
de candidaturas raúl que acaban viviendo
durante unas dos semanas en una nave que
tiene el tamaño de la cápsula más grande
que se podría mandar con un cohete a
marte y en estas dos semanas viven
enfrentándose a las dificultades que
podrían tener los humanos si van de
visita o si finalmente se instalan en
marte pues comiendo comida deshidratada
durmiendo en la cama que el periodista
describe como del tema del tamaño de
ataúdes teniendo acceso acceso a 90
segundos de ducha cada tres días y de
hecho el periodista comenta bueno pues
también que no pueden salir al exterior
sin sus respectivos trajes de
astronautas y que los seis voluntarios
con los que se encuentra tienen pues
procedencias muy distintas hay un
productor de reality hay una paramédico
pero que todos comparten una pasión por
la ciencia ficción y que bien ven con
buenos ojos la exploración espacial
privada protagonizada entre otros por el
on mars que de hecho es uno de las
personas que financia este proyecto
vivirías en marte rosa bueno no creo
yo creo que tampoco me envidio a estoy
hablando de colonización espacial vamos
a hacer algún artículo independent que
aborda la propuesta al zintan que armes
miedo de privatizar la luna eso es
podría parecer una idea distópica pero
la verdad es que es una propuesta de la
que se han hecho eco distintos son
medios como este índice en que depende
de the independant del reino unido y
esta propuesta aboga por privatizar la
luna de hecho dividirla en distintas
parcelas que corresponderían a las
distintas naciones y que los distintos
países del mundo puedan explotar
económicamente sus territorios lunares
para el turismo espacial entre otras
cosas y así financiar digamos pues
acabar con los problemas que enfrentamos
aquí en la tierra pero déjame destacar
raúl que esto de momento está prohibido
por el tratado del espacio de naciones
unidas- de
1967 una tratado unos marcos pues que
este fin sam adam smith el nombre
también lo dice un poco todo pues se
quieren dejar en el olvido gracias
gracias a rosa por esta revista de
prensa mañana por supuesto el bus con
más